la première élection municipale le débat
madame monsieur bienvenue dans notre
débat en radio film est visible en
direct sur notre chaîne youtube
martinique la première un débat consacré
à la ville des trois îles et que j'ai le
plaisir d'animer avec jean-marc partis
bourgeois map
oui bonjour bonsoir à tout en aidant aux
auditrices aux auditeurs et aux
internautes
alors deux candidats sont en lice nous
vous les présentons par ordre
alphabétique je marque
oui tout d'abord arnaud rené corail qui
est le mien c'est un des trois îles et
je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il est le des
deux douaniers en exercice de comme
maire avec votre homologue de rivière
salée
andré lesieur nos grandes et corey
bonsoir bonsoir j'ai encore ti est bien
c'est d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes âgé de 66 ans vous avez
longtemps travaillé à la banque vous
êtes cadres supérieurs de boeck donc à
la retraite aujourd'hui vous mener la
liste trois îles et nouvelle dynamique
soutenue par le parti progressiste
martiniquais
vous êtes également vice président de
l'espace sud après avoir été président
de l'ancêtre de la communauté
d'agglomération doit quitter la
communauté de communes de l'espace sud
de la martinique de 2004 à 2008 je
rappelle également que vous avez été
conseiller général tendu quand on est
trois idées de 2004 à 2015 et vice
président du département de 2011 à 2015
donc jusqu'à sa disparition puisque la
hausse est générale a laissé la place à
la 7e
alors face à vous en ou redécouvrir l
iaa ch sainte-rose bonjour monsieur
santos 55 ans vous avez 55 ans des
experts immobiliers vous mener la liste
rassemblement démocratique il est un
fait divers gauche conseiller municipal
d'opposition membres d'europe écologie
les verts et si votre première
participation en tant que tête de liste
alors sans tarder nous allons passer à
la présentation de la commune les trois
îles et sont situés dans le sud ouest de
la martinique la commune fait face à
fort-de-france d'ailleurs on peut s'y
rendre en bateau
andy part du chef lieu ou emprunter la
route des ans ville touristique
les trois îles et s'étale sur 28 km
carrés à travers quatre ensembles
urbains relativement éloigné le bourg où
se situent les bâtiments administratifs
et l'église principale lance mi-temps la
pointe du bout et l'insalan la commune
compte tout 7340 habitant les îles et un
une population diminution par rapport à
alors les personnalités des trois îles
et sont nombreuses joséphine de
beauharnais tascher de la pagerie qui
pose qui avait poussé napoléon bonaparte
premier suzanne roussy 6r écrivaine
épouse d'aimé césaire l'artiste
sculpteur peintre coco rené corail ou
encore le docteur vétérinaire robert ros
vous êtes qui a été maire des trois îles
et de 1953 1971 et qui a créé le musée
de la pagerie voilà donc le temps est
venu de notre dame est tout d'abord
monsieur je vous propose d'écouter
quelques réactions dit les hyènes et des
liens se sont c'est le nom et des
habitants des trois îles et c'est un
micro trottoir comme nous disions dans
notre jargon
il n'a absolument pas valeur de sondage
le répète notre repas entre is bien
qu'un quart est aussi rendue dans la
commune et au hasard de ses
pérégrinations dans le bond des trois
îles et à poser quelques questions aux
habitants de votre commune que je vous
demande d'écouté pour les commenter
après jusqu'à présent j'ai vu que les
choses bougent pas tellement les routes
sur vous donnez à 2000 encore des
avancées à faire sur la commune on va
aller à fort-de-france par la route
on est obligé d'attendre un taxi
d'aisance dans l'est par contre monsieur
la mairie et prêt à s'occuper de l'hôtel
grand hôtel alors qu'à d'autres choses à
faire
tels que maisons les jeunes y en a une
mais se trouve à l'insalan dans le bourg
mais mieux nantes du tout pas commettre
d infrastructures déjà pour les enfants
aire de jeux pour les enfants pour les
petits il manque quand même quelques
trucs possède l'école pour avoir un
petit peu l'aération est tous au niveau
de l'école il faut s'occuper des jeunes
avant et ensuite voir tout ce qui est
grandiose sous la commune jeudi m en
salle de sport des magasins chaussures
vêtements dans le bois
il n'y a pas suffisamment libre de
service tout ce qu'on doit faire c'est
rivière salée au fort de france voir et
puis manque un peu d'activité s'est pas
à chaque fois qu'il y ait peut-être que
l'icône vacances de carnaval
une animation quand même moi je veux
dire ça ouais pour autant ce qui
concerne les projets proprement de la
ville on n'est pas questionné en règle
générale alors le tirage au sort vous a
désigné ses ancêtres aux pour commencer
cette émission quelle est votre réaction
à ce micro trottoir à écouter je pense
que je serai pas présent si tout
marchait la présence justement montrent
qu' on a des choses à faire avancer dans
cette ville on a des attentes et nous et
redit en tout cas depuis 2014 on s'est
affiché sur cette perspective faire
avancer les choses faire sortir les
bouger parce que bon ya pas d
investissement particulier je suis cette
ville qu'est ce que vous retenez de ce
micro trottoir
par exemple on pas par beaucoup parlé du
trou du transport du manque
d'investissements écoutez vous parler de
ce programme de ceux de ce qui a été dit
c'est parler du podium aujourd'hui on a
plusieurs axes de développement et dans
les axes de développement on a
effectivement la partie transport qui
est très importante en oeuvre unique
oreilles ouverts sur une question pour
vous la mère des trois îles qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce que on a entendu
ici ou là au hasard
oui bien sûr on sait pertinemment qu'il
a toujours manqué quelque chose qui ne
va pas qu'il manque c'est une
infrastructure de toutes les façons la
commune quel que soit ce qu on poserait
comme question la population trouverait
qui manquent
il y manque des éléments mais demeure
pas moins que cette nombre de dfa
structures demeurent quand on entend que
sur la seule commune n'y a pas
d'activité c'est la seule commune à
organiser du cinéma tous les mois sur le
front de mer animé les animations
quasiment jeu c'est vrai qu'il ya chez
juillet-août avec fouilles dina
qui est arrivé depuis 2014 parce que
voilà et qui quand même à nîmes trois
îles et les manifestations se déroulent
tout le long au niveau des différents
quartiers de la ville
il y as matière de transport certes le
transport urbain ou interurbain où il
faut attendre effectivement le taxi de
deux défenseurs les poussent à vendre
afro de france ne pouvait pas dire que
le transport urbain c'est à dire sud
liban qui dans les deux sens on peut se
rendre à partir d'un bus mis en place
pas l'espace sud
à l'époque j'ai fait une initiative et
là ça a continué avec sublime
donc il existe un transport est mis et
puis le meilleur transport qui existe à
la martinique ce transport maritime
entre fort-de-france il y trois idées
donc on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
un système de transport il ya un bus qui
fait aussi les quartiers qui
malheureusement le plus souvent vides on
va on va y revenir un jour on va parler
du transport mais avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet une question d'actualité
deux cas de corona virus ceux détectés
en martinique il s'agit de deux médecins
suisses
un suisse et un italien un homme et une
femme qui devait participer à un
colloque sur le cancer de la thyroïde
ces médecins étaient logés dans un hôtel
de la pointe du bout votre réaction
monsieur serge eux ont subi puisque
c'est l'actualité vous savez on a parlé
de 100 mille cas que j'ai vu au niveau
de la presse donc ça veut dire qu'on est
en train d'arriver syndicats dans le
monde est donc on est ce une pandémie on
sait très bien ce qui s'est passé sur
les bateaux de croisière et que certains
n'ont pas pu accoster dans certaines sur
certaines îles donc on est vraiment sur
moins de suspicion pour que ça arrive
chez nous
aussi attendait pas aussi tout mais nous
sommes en période touristique
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya des allées et
venues il ya du monde qui vient qui va
donc on pourra pas empêcher sa
propagation a donc mal mon interrogation
c'est maintenant qu'elles sont va faire
parce qu'on est une petite île et ma
crainte c'est que dans cette petite île
où il ya quatre cent mille habitants -
quatre cent mille habitants
comment réagir quelle réaction qu'il
faut avoir et ce qu'il faut qu'on
continue à accueillir systématiquement
vous savez faut qu'on se pose cette
réflexion lemire avant de vous poser la
question monsieur aumont et corey
monsieur sainte rose lemire a assigné en
justice le préfet et la rs demandant la
fermeture des frontières
si une solution est un principe de
précaution
en tout cas il faut qu'on analyse je
pense qu'on est un peu léger moi
j'écoutais un peu les nouvelles et je
trouve que le monde scientifique ne sait
pas encore vraiment exprimer là on a que
le monde politique et ses fruits le
monde scientifique via le directeur de
la santé oui mais c'est pas suffisant il
faut qu'aujourd'hui qu'on entend le plus
ce monde et qu'il nous dise un peu bas
les réactions et les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour éviter cela c'est une
pandémie à mon avis monsieur rené corail
oui bon mais sur ces opérations de
fermer les ibos
c'est ça peut permettre une réaction de
la population de se protéger je pense
que c'est plus de ce sens là et par
contre on la ville et rose hill et nous
avons déjà une initiative déjà entre eux
mer pour se rencontrer parce que nous
avons l'arrivée par la mer des
impromptus partir des voiliers
hier nous étions effectivement un rendez
vous avec le préfet directeur de la rse
dieccte et le recteur ou prendre des
dispositions à partir pas de clément
pour les élèves à partir de lundi ce que
la ville je pense que l'ensemble des
communes sont en train de mettre en
oeuvre permettent effectivement aux
enfants de n'est dupe du savon en
quantité du papier quantité pour
permettre effectivement aux enfants de
se protéger ou éviter cela évitez d'une
contamination quelconque bien sûr de nos
services administratifs bien sûr les
affiches ont été apposées du savon
mise à disposition de tout un chacun
les affiches qui pourraient être
récupérées en mairie dans les services
publics de la mairie et des commerçants
qui ont voulu mettre des affiches pour
inciter ici et là le public à se laver
les mains le plus souvent possible
voilà ce que nous avons fait aux trois
idées je me suis rendu effectivement bon
bien sûr hier soir j'ai eu l'appel le
directeur de la rs avant même que la
presse sera informée et ensuite ce matin
effectivement je me suis rendu à l'hôtel
bakwa fond dans quel état effectivement
été un peu le personnel le directeur et
je suis un peu inquiété de sa maison
tout cela crée une psychose
ici aux 3 cl et parce que la ville les
trois îles et vibre beaucoup du tourisme
mais avec les restaurants les hôtels les
monuments et autres places fortes sites
à visiter est ce que vous ne craignez
pas au ralentissement de l'activité
économique
interrogeant les hôteliers il y a déjà
des effectivement des annulations de
séjours bon maintenant espérons que que
ça ne va pas l'hécatombe rico n'ai pas
d'autre cas hier effectivement à la rsc
dit de toutes les façons il y aura des
cas la martinique parce que on ne peut
pas ils ont fermé
lille prévu qui a des martiniquais qui
avec ce qui s'est passé en guyane donc
démotique ex en guyane qui reviennent
qu'il vienne martinique il y avait dans
la salle quelqu'un qui revenait de
guyenne pote justement donc on ne peut
pas assez difficile puis à ceux qui
arrivent par bateau comme vous voulez
dit affirmé lille
donc on est n'est pas à l'abri qui en
ait d'autres
d'autres cas la martinique mais n'allons
pas vers la psychose nous prônons faut
prendre les dispositions pour éviter
cela donc
se laver les mains sur ceux qui
préconisaient ne pas s'embrasser de ne
pas voilà ne pas se faire pouces thioune
donc dolo dans les bureaux d'accueil et
autres est-ce que cela a un impact sur
la tenue de la campagne sur les meetings
par exemple est-ce que ça peut avoir un
impact
nous sommes nous avons nous prendre nos
précautions comme dans les entreprises
comme on arrivait chez vous on se salue
on ici on évite d'avoir eu des contacts
alors si vrai que yvan une pénurie en
tout cas de diderot seule théorie dont
alcool et qu on un principe de
précaution même si si on n'a pas ce
réflexe c'est naturel conviennent qu on
dise bonjour mon maintenant sur la
campagne pour l'instant je ne pense pas
que ce n'est pas encore arrivé dans une
psychose
alors on nous entrons dans le vif du sud
eut dit bahain d'abord en parlant de
votre bilan
monsieur rené corail je suppose que vous
lui jugé positif en quoi est il positif
il est positif parce que il fait bon
vivre ou trois idées beaucoup de
personnes y habitent et est bon nous en
sommes fiers que tout ceux qui viennent
et qui qui sont aujourd'hui des îles et
un soin de soi qui sont arrivés qui sont
des îliens que nous accueillons comme
toujours dans nos écoles dans nos
entreprises dans l'administration dans à
l'hôpital maison de retraite il y à
toutes ces personnes qui sont arrivées
aux 3es et qui se trouve qu'être que
dans dans un cadre agréable très vrai
que cela dépend revient à à ces fameux
30 ans quand on dit mais trois et il y
en a qui sont arrivés et qu'ils ne
savent pas du tout ce qu'ils disent et 3
il en 1989 et 3 il est aujourd'hui en
2020 qu'est-ce qu'elle travaille chez
nos qualités
qu'est ce qui a changé depuis spectacle
lorient dormait moins de choses ont
changé
déjà il était très difficile de pouvoir
construire trois îles et où auparavant
parce que l'assainissement était
obsolète complètement
on ne pouvait plus à accorder de permis
de construire y ait tout ça après il ya
eu tout quand on est des fous
l'animation sportive l'animation
culturelle fond de mer les les écoles on
a fait des travaux les quartiers que
nous avons fait dès août
il ya plein de choses si je prends la
dernière mandature ce qu'on dit cas pas
de bilan de la mandature ses 14 millions
de travaux avec par exemple le centre
d'accueil de la petite enfance qui est
une crèche l'ailier à l'école maternelle
les travaux au niveau des écoles c'est
plutôt mignon dick ii de travaux
réhabilitation d'un canada lance
mi-temps maison pour tous en salle à
nantes on a entendu parlé tout à l'heure
et nous continuons avec un terrain que
nous agrandissons pour les jeunes qui
jouent au foot ou et y compris mettre à
la disposition d'une école de rugby
aujourd'hui le rugby est revenu ce avait
existé avec moi quand j'étais président
de la v en 1982 aujourd'hui le rugby à
nouveau existe est à nouveau gagne aussi
ses galons tout cela grâce effectivement
la fois studieux que nous avons créé
alors vous en citer les des abus de
certaines épices daf litige l'évacuation
des eaux pluviales à lens mi temps et
tout ceci travaux il ya énormément de
choses si c'est pour vous citer le
nombre de choses ces 94 millions d'euros
de travaux réalisés les six dernières
années
si je prends ce qui s'est passé avec les
quatre autres mandature c'est énorme et
c'est de là que ça te permet
effectivement que des personnes bien
s'installer nous avons d'accord monsieur
monsieur sainte rose je suppose que vous
êtes alors vous êtes conseiller
municipal de l'opposition depuis 2014
je suppose que vous n'avez vraiment pas
la même vision me satisfaire de cette
autosatisfaction je vous ai dit que je
ne serais pas là si toutes les choses
fonctionnent et quel serait l'intérêt
d'une candidature si le résultat est
positif c'est la seule commune
je ne veux pas comparer et faire le
bilan des autres ou bien celle et a fait
des investissements est bien celle là
fait de nouveaux investissements on voit
que cette commune bouge je suis désolé
une commune majeurs comme la note ce qui
est quasiment une porte d'entrée une
porte de sortie du sud avec un quartier
kiters quartier de 2,3 il n a pas évolué
non qu'on ne dise pas ça quand on arrive
en 2014 en avait déjà fait le con t'as
le constat nous on poursuit sur le même
constat on a observé pendant six ans le
bo est toujours
au tube au ciment il n'y a aucune
infrastructure il n'y a pas deux
méritent aucune mairie n'était 35 ans 30
ans n'a pas construit la mairie tél en
trente ans la mairie la mairie est
toujours violent je ne souhaite à
personne je suis il est donc je
n'insulte personne je vois qu'il faut je
crois que il faut il faut qu'on fasse le
vrai qu'en ce temps moi je vais pas
reprocher à monsieur le maire d'avoir
son mandat d'avoir son bilan c'est son
bilan aujourd'hui on la déroute à
reconstruire
quand je suis dans les quartiers que ce
soit avant sa lane où j'habite vous
habitez que ce soit à la plaine que ça
soit dans des quartiers comme la bouffon
il ya toujours des doutes à faire il y a
des routes et des liquides et des
quartiers qui ne sont pas quand je
prends glacis qui n'est pas relié à la
pointe où les gens sont toujours dans
des bouts de terre
donc il ya un vrai travail vous donner
pour satisfaire la population parce
qu'il ya une attente
moi j'ai des commerçants qui viennent
dans le bourg qui remballe leurs
affaires et qui nous ramène dans affaire
est ce que c'est une situation de
développement économique on a un beau en
un beau touristiques ont un beau où il
fait bon vivre
il fait mon but de buffon se sont se
sont ce sont les gens qui font connaît
on aime le beau le biais voudrait ce qui
vous paraît g7 rose le plus négatif le
plus répréhensibles et critiquable du
dernier mandat la dernière place la non
action cette léthargie
on fait rien on se contente de faire des
petits travaux sur des petites choses
qui sont dites chose obligatoire quand
on me parle de maison pour tous quand on
me parle de certains esprits des fois su
que ce soit des petits travaux se sont
pas des travaux majeurs
cette commune est une commune
touristique aujourd'hui nous avons perdu
l'office du tourisme
vous imaginez on a perdu le classement
de l'office zurichois dit le classement
des 10 de la ville en perdant perdant
l'office du tourisme
le classement de nos fils au calme car
on a permis une l'office du tourisme
dans le classement de la ville qu'on
pouvait avoir par la suite et malgré
tout on avait eu quand même une
certification qui nous permettait
d'aller qui nous permettait d'y aller
donc je suis désolé on ne peut pas
manager une ville touristique comme on
manage nouvelle ouvre les op les offices
du tourisme pas été rattachées nous
la 3 il est comme le marin pouvait
garder l'office du tourisme est allé au
delà c'est à dire devenir une ville ils
ne seront la paix la commune touristique
la commune classée tourisme ça nous
permettait d'avoir des dotations de
financement est il là dessus c'est un
point négatif manque de dynamisme dans
le divertissement
allez je vais pousser le bouchon plus
encore plus loin l'ambition mais
l'impression qu'il suffit pas d'habiter
un lieu il faut y vivre
je crois que ce monsieur une vie pas 3
il est alors que la population y vit
il y a les activités c'est la seule
commune installer des chapiteaux sur la
place publique permettant à des artisans
pendant une période touristique de
vendre déplore produits low production
locale voo profond les productions
qu'ils ajoutent achète à l'extérieur me
dit est un marché qui vit nous sommes
monsieur dans une commune entre 5000 et
9000 habitants ne sommes pas comme lié à
salé entre 10000 et 20000 habitants
les budgets sont pas les mêmes les
recettes ne sont pas les mêmes aussi
l'avis rosselin 7486 oui mais l'autre
côté c'est 12 milles cap 13 mille
habitants ses 24 millions de budget de
recettes et nous ses 12 millions de
recettes
ce que vous simplement des activités
existent à rivière-salée depuis des
années des années qui a permis
effectivement la voir ce budget avec une
étendue qui est qui n'est pas de de 28
kilomètres carrés donc il ya tout cela
il faut que mettre tout cela en relation
par rapport à une commune comme trois
îles et qui est certes une commune
touristique 7 qui avait l'office de
tourisme qui a été arrêté parce que y'a
une initiative qui a été prise il faut
peut-être à louer à des initiatives qui
s'est arrêté mon chemin
moi je voulais pas continuer dans le
sens où certains voulaient l'emmener
j'avais plus à ce moment là je constate
en fait tous ces gens qui aujourd'hui
disent certain nombre de choses c'était
du des grillades
il me ygrié pourront y faisait des
grillades on met en face de moi et
aujourd'hui 10
il faut savoir que la dgf la commune et
troisième n'a pas diminué d'affaires
global de fonctionnement tation
malheureux dizaine d'années l'office de
tourisme 10 dans le cas de la loisne
l'autre soit transféré dans le cas de la
communauté d'agglo avec l'outil les lois
parce que des mines depuis 1996 s'il y
avait une distinction
et tout cela à été englobé à la demande
de l'association nationale des élus du
littoral idée est venue du tourisme pour
que cette dgf qui tape comptée à part
soit englobé ça n'a jamais changé le la
commune a toujours perçu ça dgf telle
qu'elle est capable dit même s'il avait
lancé la chine 2 3 et loire changer
tristesse à la veille de cette du sénat
où nous allons mettre en place un
service du tourisme
parce que c'est possible toutes les
façons c'est la seule c'est la commune
ça sera la commune touristique que le
préfet va nous attribuer des rois 5 août
de l'année 2020 2021 et à ce moment là
ce que nous avons perdu c'est la taxe de
séjour qui et nous allons continuer à
participer à l'élaboration de l'eau de
l'authie parce que ça touche ultime à
volonté de travailler parce que j'avais
dit sivom communauté d'agglo six mois
donc c'est ma volonté d'être dans
l'intercommunalité de travailler avec
l'ensemble des maires du sud de
travailler aussi avec la cité m et comme
ça toujours été parce que leur divine
nous travaillons avec la ctn pouvoir
mettre le haut débit' nager de la
question précise est ce que vous ne
craignez pas de perdre des recettes liée
à l'activité touristique non pas du tout
pas du tout si la tête de six jours
seulement que nous avons pour l'instant
perdu avec le service du tourisme mettra
en place ce sera un nouveau communes
touristiques
nous allons à nouveau prétendre à une
partie de cette taxe de séjour sur
l'état financier de la commune comment
vous voyez l'état financier de la
commune il dit nous ne confondons pas ou
quand on parle de perte de dotation
parce qu'on a perdu le fil et oui c'est
pas du tout son âge balle je parle de la
capacité est là pour la ville
d'augmenter cette dotation communes
classées touristiques nous augmente tout
à fait les communes classées
les communes classées tourisme andy
dotation complémentaire
je suis désolé non jeu là dessus la
turbie chacun vous nous avons division
deux visions différentes annonces
quoique la vision tu vous l'avez pas
puisque si vous aviez une vision on
l'aurait vu ont l'ouïe jouent centre
bourg aujourd'hui on a une vraie attente
alors qu'elle est ma attendant justement
sur le tourisme sur le développement de
ce qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire de
plus ce qui existe déjà trois îles et
havre soit une manne du fait que c'est
une place forte du patrimoine culturel
immatériel il ya la mise et de la page
guy ya d'autres endroits mais également
du patrimoine naturel et puis il y adeux
des circuits qui sont vraiment originaux
dans la commune ya des monuments il ya
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire de plus
c'est ce qu'il faudrait inventer
d'autres services celle ci il faut
inventer 2 réactivité aux développer
celles qui existent comment voyez-vous
le développement du tourisme dans la
baie il faut amplifier déjà il faut
s'occuper de ce village tous ici que
nous on n'aime pas qui est la pointe du
goût n'est pas du tout traités comme un
village touristique
nous avons une activité obtenir le deux
étoiles sur la semaine est du côté de
l'impératrice village ça fonctionnait on
disait dans les années 80 10e 2000 après
ça s'est dégradé complètement le le le
lance mi-temps s'est dégradée mais pour
que si vous vous souvenez sa
municipalité mais bien sûr puisqu'il n'y
a pas eu d'investissement aujourd'hui on
se précipite juste avant les élections
pour offert la route qui naquit même
était terminée on a perdu le fond de
mais on a peur d'une certaine visibilité
on n'a pas de square on n'a pas un
endroit où se reposer la ville n'a pas
été anticipée par contre si devenue une
place forte de promotion là oui on va
voir des bâtiments qui vont arriver là
on voulait avant une inflexion sur du
côté de lens m'arrête pour avant les
deux pôles qui sont peu ou poésie comme
la pointe du bout dans ce match où il ya
déjà un hôtel il fait revivre un peu
c'est tout elle voilà que ça devait
devenir
un endroit on a fait encore de la
promotion va densifier les réseaux ne
sont pas suffisant parce qu'on a des
voiries qui ne sont plus haut sur
lesquels sur lesquels on pourra pas on
parle parfois de croisement il n'y a pas
de réflexion globale d'aménagement
aujourd'hui les autres teulier attendre
attendre les hôteliers les
professionnels attendent un
investissement de la ville sur ces
espaces selon l'ap hm cet investissement
c'est pareil sur la pointe du bout
imaginez en un quartier qui s'appelle la
poterie qui comme un village de gaulois
il est à l'extérieur on y va en voiture
on n'y va pas en bus on ne réfléchit pas
et vous l'avez dit on a dit on a des
péages sur cette notion sur ce
territoire et ses perles ne sont pas
valorisées pour qu'on en fasse pas ce
que dit monsieur mari se bat avec ses
petites boutiques et les commerçants qui
sont dedans aussi
donc je pense qu'il faut avoir une
vision et nous ont une vision sur le
transport qui nous transporte des
transports maritimes qui soit un peu
partagé parce qu'on va rentrer en
discussion
j'ai pas j'ai commencé la discussion de
la cité mais qui loue comme vous savez
loto était organisé le cnt la 7e oui
puisque c'est la cité el fna oublié qui
était inaltérable à julien les autres
communautés d'agglomération nos gueules
on va tourner d'accord pour le transport
on parle du tracé a été transféré hier
d'accord même pau sud libre c'était donc
si l'autorité organisatrice team
monsieur le président la 7e que vous
identité c'est d'accord mais bien sûr ce
n'est pas de la santé
vous savez vous savez c'est ce petit jeu
de vases communicants sont importants
aussi ce sont des élus majeur qui siège
à des endroits identiques ne l'est pas
qu'on ait un ensemble unique
aujourd'hui donc on a un vrai travail de
réflexion et se poser pour cette année
de réflexion on a des outils on nous
habitons des outils sur notre territoire
qui imaginait on a des outils
intelligents on a pas de discussion
alors je ne sais pas si c'est parce que
ces discussions sur l'utilisation de ces
outils par exemple qu'elle peut accepter
que sur notre territoire n'est en et un
golf des floralies un certain nombre
d'équipements et que ça soit pas vous
discutez qu'on soit pas en train de
parler de 2,2 d'ambition commune
moi je ne veux pas
son huile tard j'y vais pas rentrer
villa 7e qu'ils appartiennent pas là
mais alors donc ça veut dire qu'on est
au cloisonnement on n'est pas des
martiniquais je ne siège pas j'ai peint
de conseiller territorial je ne vais pas
voir comment cet outil fonctionne il
avait une consigne eaux territoriales
pourquoi elle se retourne sur notre
liste
c'est parce qu'il ya un problème à un
moment donné à un moment donné une
difficulté vous avez souvent mais si
vous font vous fonctionner en vase clos
allez vous m'a écouté ces personnes car
les genoux vous imaginez qu on fait
comment pour les personnes qui
n'habitent pas travaillent avec nous à
fait certain travail auprès des jeunes
ménages avec vous mais elle a fait elle
a fait les municipales avec neuf
disparus depuis monsieur le procès elle
a disparu depuis le 1er janvier 2016
nous l'avons jamais suite aux élections
et le taux l'avancée du touya non parce
que vous avez perdu j'ai perdu yann j'ai
permis vont faire des ravages
je n'ai même pas vu ne s'est jamais
présentée en mairie
mais au lavo est une élue qu'elle est
depuis hier à l'espace sud mais vous
l'avez décrié à quai en faisant quoi
vous savez quand vous quand vous faites
passer faisait une lettre anonyme à tous
les élus lettres anonymes à la demande
du maire qui explique cette dame n'est à
nouveau déposer de nous dans nos casiers
compte sur cette dame moi je suis restée
moi vous souvenez pas cette lettre
anonyme coquette qui a circulé chez les
élus dix ans dix ans des mots et julien
ce secteur mais aussi oui à la demande
du maire nous distribuons chez le mail
toujours un de des services de la ville
non ce que je veux dire par là sa place
à elle l'a été mal à l'aise non je vous
dis à l'éruption
le fonctionnement et vous avez vu
comment
le fonctionnement de la ville le
fonctionnement de monsieur le maire est
un fonctionnement particulier
je n'ai pas fais partie de ceux de sa
majorité je n'ai jamais fait partie de
son équipe
tous les comptes administratifs et oui
ils sont mille soit il choisit qu ils
sont bâtis dans son bon sens bombe et
guti voilà vous savez jouer c'est ce que
j'ai expliqué il se tient compte
administratif atone le voter mais pas
certaine mais pendant que contador
vous pouvez voter contre je vous
explique john et je vote un budget vous
abstenez vous abstenir été votée et je
vote quant au budget original puisque
l'ambition entre le maire quand on me
dit j'ai vos dépenses et 5 fautes
administratives sont bonnes ce sont les
réalisations qu est ce qu il vous seriez
content
un contact a expliqué mois non il avait
mené puis il a bien compris on se gausse
de pouvoir voter nous n'est pas une
opposition vous dire on va voter contre
il n'a son compte il n'est pas un
sincère donc il fallait une épaisse 1 74
million dit non à fait illégal et vient
des quatre îles à vous dépensez dépenses
mais les à dépenser mais non sans
ambition
c'est un budget sans ambition si son
ambition on peut voter contre un
investissement
quand on vote des investissements on
pourrait être amené à monter contre un
investissement qui était qui est illégal
vous moi qui celui qu'il veut faire sur
le fond de mer qui est le gym ce qui a
été voté qui a été voté le hall des
sports qui a été voté en conseil
municipal sur un site qui n'est pas le
bon site
là on peut être amené à voter contre 6
il le sent mais par contre
d'ici là on a une cohérence un vous
savez il faut qu'on soit content de ce
qu'on fait alors on y signale originaux
notre confrère me joseph qui assurent le
chronométrage rappelle comme un
chronométrage ici nous signale que vous
avez tous les deux le même temps de
parole comme minutes donc ça nous permet
de rééquilibrer et non car nos oreilles
vous ont manqué d'ambition vase clos et
vous êtes là depuis trop longtemps ça
fait trente
no 31 ans 7 et doyen des maires donc est
ce que je me sens oui j'essaie de
traduire visé par qu'elle est là donc
les là l'illustration de somme de son
manque d'ambition
est ce que ça veut dire vous êtes en
bout de course vous n'avez plus qu'à
dire je n'ai pas du tout novation simple
aussi la population allemand jeudi à la
population il est n qu'elle va recevoir
à partir de samedi
on va alors on se met avec un nouvelle
équipe dynamique parce que j'ai beaucoup
de jeunes qui rejoignent et des anciens
élus qui ont laissé leur place à
d'autres n'ont pas madame pinville
madame pinville gelé pas revu depuis le
1er janvier 2016 raconter des histoires
ici parce qu'on veut une place parce
qu'on veut retourner à la 7e
et puis quelle est l'ambition de madame
c'est l'ambition de madame pinville ont
ils se disent se fait avoir exactement
de la même manière qu'elle m'avait eu
des manques lyonnais avec mon frère avec
d'autres bons bon c'est fait c'est fait
moi je reviens pas en arrière
je dirais simplement des mises à part
ouvert la presse libérale et de recevoir
12 pages de ce que nous nous allons
réaliser au cours des six prochaines
années
elle m'a toujours fait confiance sait
pertinemment ce que je vais réaliser en
ce qui concerne le hall des sports il
faut mise à part que ce soit passé trois
fois au conseil municipal trois fois
pour trouver le lieu
il y avait en sallaz n'y avait le stade
d'une heure il y avait sur fond de mer
89 de 1985 jean né de ses dents des
ambitions du bâti depuis 89 dans les
ambitions du relatifs à aussi le radar
des instructions de l'ampleur des
ambitions un cimetière paysager tout
cela fait partie de la fonction vous
n'avez pas pu se réaliser
est-ce que je me justifie qu'on prévoit
toutes les visions que nous avons est ce
qu'on peut les réaliser
2 au fil des années nous réalisons un
certain nombre d'infrastructures
permettant aux il est un atout ce qui n
habitent et 3 il est de mieux vivre
il ya les écoles il ya les routes les
bons prix la cité des des chemins que
nous avons réalisé qu'il faut maintenant
nouveau et après 30 ans au fait je
comprends et j'en ai fait beaucoup cette
année nous avons nous sommes obligés
municipal a fait à l'hispano nous sommes
avec des entreprises à réaliser des
travaux lors le 10 sport monsieur pour
savoir pourquoi
en fait mis à part le lieu avait été
retenu à la fin y avait dans la zone
artisanale de la table derrière des
ateliers nous avons fait l'étude de sol
il y avait pour trois cent mille euros
de surcoût et puis lorsque nous déposons
les dossiers de financement il faut
serrer au niveau du feder est fait ce
matini conseil régional 2014 2020 adopté
par la commission économique européenne
le 18 décembre 2014
pour mouvoir l'inclusion sociale et
lutter contre la pauvreté toute forme de
discrimination priorités
d'investissement choisi investir dans
des infrastructures sociales et
sanitaires contribuer au développement
nationale régionale locale radio des
inégalités sur le plan est absente et
favoriser l'inclusion sociale pour un
accès amélioré aux services sociaux
culturels et créatifs récréatif le
passage services additionnels
quand monsieur le préfet est venu a dit
monsieur le maire vous avez tout à fait
raison d'avoir real que vous réalisiez
ce ce bijou demain parce que sera sera
un bijou sur le front de mer qu'on
ajoutera à cet endroit là parce que vous
êtes à proximité des écoles primaires
monsieur me dis il faut faire une
convention avec le avec la ctm pour que
les enfants de l'école primaire puisse
se rendre au collège dans le hall du
collège qu' il ya une association de
trois ilets qui l'utilisent que il faut
que les multi activités si pour les
personnes âgées à proximité des hlm ya
tout ça quand il parle de poterie
monsieur sainte rose poterie est une
propriété privée
nous sommes toujours en relation avec la
ville avec la société poterie mais c'est
une société et une entreprise totalement
privée comment allons nous et nous faire
des acquisitions ou faire ce nombre de
choses dans une propriété privée j'entre
pas chez vous pour faire des travaux
chez vous si vous avez l'ambition en
même temps de faire des travaux privés
pour monsieur
marie vous avez peut-être d'autres
ambitions de faire d'autres contrats
vous privez vous d'autres personnes non
monsieur comme vous voilà et c'est aussi
en ce qui concerne la pointe de la cie
la pointe
là encore il n'y a pas de route
simplement parce que vous allez
traverser des soutes des propriétés
privées d'accord pour mettre au cd mais
vous avez fait des routes sur les petits
dépôts vite et privé puisque vous passez
en commu conseil municipal cette
rétrocession et ce passage anticipé vous
le faites 2 2 en losange eric vous avez
récupéré quelqu'un qui a barré la route
j'ai dû lui prouver que 1700 ans en 1774
c'est là où tu existes j'ai dû aller en
dhr joue les documents que j'ai dû
récupérer aux archives voulu montrer que
cette route est une chemin rural et
qu'il fallait la faire et nous le
cabaret la population est en train en ce
moment dabach et les gens voilà la messe
mais il y aura un chemin alaoui neuf
mois jusqu'à des parkings allawi 9 sur
les terrains vous publierez 1874 une
histoire ancienne as roma 6e 3 nous
reste plus que quelques minutes mais
est-ce que vous avez un projet
emblématique qui pourrait fédérer qui
pourrait d'après vous convaincre la
population de voter pour votre équipe
le problème c'est que je ne veux pas
satisfaire tout le monde si j'en parle
je parle qu'une seule parce que les tous
les quartiers sont concernés dans le
bout on a quinze mille véhicules jour
qui passe et qui qu'une mise en scène on
a demandé cet cette déviation elle était
ici à l'aise il est le maire le maire
actuel a essayé de faire ce déviation et
ça a fait monter au tollé des
populations en a
une façade maritime on n'a pas de centre
nautique un vrai centre nautique un pas
un centre juste vous faire de l'avion
mais vrai centre nautique sur lequel le
grenier pourra se mettre notre fierté le
goût mais nous sommes champions on a eu
nos vocations que les championnes et
l'autre qui qui qui suit derrière
on a une ambition si cette ambition
c'est de mettre en place des
infrastructures parce que effectivement
on parle de scolaires mais les scolaires
aussi envie de faire du nautisme on est
tourné vers la mer cette infrastructure
n'est plus d'actualité
elle date de 89 moi j'ai la liste est
impossible que quand on arrivait aux
trois ilets en 89 90 il y avait un
problème majeur quitter pour monter avec
l'aide du conseil général à l'époque
sus aux poteries ils ont eu peur car
vous vous souvenez pas on s'est vu à
l'époque dans les années 90 91 souffert
ce projet majeur
usan pacy a été associé parce qu'il y
avait une école de cinéma il y avait un
aménagement bola vous avez eu peur vous
venez d'arriver on ne savait même pas
vous êtes élu non mais je vous rappelle
je vous rappelle j'étais là présent
qu'on a défendu ce projet monsieur sisi
ici monsieur mais j'étais présent vous
souhaitez annoncer comme vous étiez hier
j'étais toujours jeu
je rappelle que je suis j'étais
président jacques martin
c'est le 4 juin le fonds qui gère les
faux de la gestion de la formation vous
foot professionnel nous avons annoncé
avec le physique de rénovation du centre
bourg on l'a fait ou sainte anne on a
fait vous le lamantin vous pour eux pour
le marin quand j'ai demandé à monsieur
le maire dia dizaine d'années qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour le bourg il ya une
dizaine d'années qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour le bouger des fonds on va mettre du
fisac
on va rénover le bon jusqu'à maintenant
j'attends la réponse il n'y a pas de
volonté il faut pour nous et il faut que
tu fasses mi temps il faut qu'on aille
au lancement la pointe du bout aussi
parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse un vrai
village créole qu'on ait une réflexion
notamment la piétonnisation de certaines
voies nous parle de la piétonnisation de
la rue chat on parle de mettre en place
un petit parc
en fait vous convient de se reposer
parce qu'il ya la mer mais aussi
l'intérieur
il faut qu'on ait un vrai visage on n'a
pas cette ambition nous nous jouons
petit pour l'instant nous jouons tous
petits et sur l'animation du bout je
veux terminer
eminem mission du bo vous savez c'est
les gens de l'extérieur ceux qui y
vivent
les 7500 qui y vivent il va falloir
qu'il travaille dessus et deuxième époux
terminer l'un placement à tous il y aura
ce centre multi activités est dans une
voie d'engorgement je crois même que le
dise dans un avis négatif parce qu'on
cas d'évacuation qu'est ce qui va se
passer quand il voit du tournoi le sud
non je suis désolé on est passé au youth
alors surtout ça il faut qu'on soit
monsieur l'économie nationale tous les
avis des gens s'ils s'imposent tous les
avis parce que c'est sûr on voulait
payer quelqu'un pour lui demander de ne
pas se porter sur les choix contre connu
deux journées
je vois présidence et les trois îles et
ville ancrée dans l'avenir avec la zenn
la cdm aux zones de mouillage organisée
qui est prévu j'étais encore judy jeudi
matin mardi matin 3 3 mars
j'étais encore sous préfecture ou pour
faire financer l'aménagement de la
marine à 300 et quelques milles euros
dans le cadre de convergence convergence
plus de 300000 euros dans le cadre de
convergence aussi l'aménagement la mise
en place de ces démos savez dans dans la
baie du 3 il est ce que nous avons fait
obtenu balisage complète la zone ça
c'est du travail et administratif mais
du travail que sa demande pouvoir le
faire nous arrivons demandé la mission
comprend mais mais il ya tellement de
choses à dire effectivement la
population je reviens la population vont
retrouver
effectivement dans notre document qu'on
va leur livrée samedi que toutes nos
ambitions et la mise en place dans cette
année mots ce qui veut dire que vous
savez son
la marine a rénové qui notre point
d'ancrage pour pouvoir gérer cette
partie maritime dont nous demande la
population mise à part cela je citerai
pas ce que les jeunes de mon équipe
reçoivent les jeunes des trois îles et
dimanche matin m'ont demandé jeudi les
jeunes de l'équipe on les recevoir
dimanche matin mais je dis je lirai
simplement la prise de la vice
présidente du ccas me dit mais voilà ce
qui se fait en direction des jeunes aide
financière aux études et formations
partenariat associations et familles
pour l'accompagnement des nouveaux
étudiants sur la france et que nous
tweetons de jeunesse
oui ça c'est le bilan du travail demain
ville que vous tenez la commune à
l'épisode de la mission locale
pourquoi madame question de la mission
locale qui a accompagné ces jeux même
chose je veux dire les conseils locaux
dernier de son bilan allez demander à
menacer son bilan vous êtes à l'ami jean
marie ils sont bien l'état de
l'ascension les cales se sont bio local
vous plaît visiblement son neveu qu'à la
licence il a lancé un audit ou mais
c'est le burn out de 2 sachez messieurs
les journalistes je suis reconnaissant
et on va pas vous avez pour mission de
retrouver les deux agents des routes 17
ce madame pinville si vous voulez parler
de ça beaucoup alors
d'abord avant de clôturer nous allons
passer la parole torturé à monsieur à
monsieur cherche la chose vous avez une
minute chrono normes
c'est parti pour votre conclusion
tabitha nées choisi les habitants des
trois îles et le 15 mars e2020 vous
désignerez votre colère la prochaine
mandature 2020 2026 et vous aurez le
choix entre poursuivre l' immobilisme
trentenaire est celui de construire un
avenir vous notre ville je pense qu'il
faut que vous fassiez le bon choix en
votant pour le rassemblement
démocratique n'est pas ce que nous avons
une équipe prête à retrousser ses
manches et qui ne va pas simplement
faire de la programmation mais nous
aurons également également un calendrier
d'action qu'on va vous soumettre donc
fait confiance à notre un autre liste et
voter en masse pour le rassemblement
démocratique et lien ici à sainte rose
merci monsieur sainte rose maintenant
c'est sûr nicora la cij dit
effectivement à la population et les
haines comme d'habitude on m'avait fait
confiance pendant ces sites comptant
pour le travail effectué avec des
équipes renouvelées tous les six ans
avec des personnes et ni à une volonté
de travailler pour la commune ce qui a
été le cas pendant entre 2014 et 2020
vous l'avez reconnu nous repartons avec
une équipe renouvelée avec de nouveaux
jeunes aussi particulièrement les jeunes
dames qui sont très dynamiques participe
avec moi dans le cas de cette campagne
et qui vont qui vont recevoir cette
genèse ce dimanche matin et qui vont
dimanche après midi et qui vont discuter
avec eux pour pouvoir aussi très heureux
les entendre sur leur avenir qu est ce
qu on pourrait proposer qu'est-ce qu'il
secoue très et puis trois îles et c'est
la mer 3 y laisser la petite enfance
trois îles et sur le développement
économique trois îles et c'est le
développement du tourisme 3 il est si
les jeunes et les aménagements
touristiques depuis 2
le cap nous travaillons avec la région
avec la ctm y compris le poulet honneur
c'est nous c'est tout le travail
quotidien mer avec la ctm contrairement
à ce qu'on pense merci beaucoup
donc voilà cette émission était remis
doute n'est une émission assez
mouvementée au mac quelles sont vos
prochains rendez vous oui alors nos
prochains rendez-vous en rappelant que
les missions ont été réalisées
aujourd'hui par adel le doubs avec au
chronométrage michel joseph
les prochains débats en radio auront
lieu aura lieu le prochain débat ce sera
le dernier avec les trois candidats du
lourd 1 ce sera ce lundi 9 et puis le
lendemain mardi ce sera le dernier de
nos débats télévision avec laurent
defrance des débats qui seront
présentées mardi en tout cas par
christine cupides et franck deux ans
c'est ainsi que nous allons vous guider
avec nos invités sainte-rose et en
auront une oreille candidats à vaulruz
aux municipales et communautaires de la
ville les trois i les élections
municipales le débat